you have a free story structure training
course on your website uh no I'm going
to do it right now I'm going to do it
for
exclusively film courage uh viewers
because here's something I know about
you you're really smart now how do I
know that you're watching film courage
so um yeah I I talk at a lot of places
like film courage and I try to give
information that I hope people find
helpful but you know what's always
frustrating for me is I can't really get
into the secret sauce of what I teach
writers because
they pay money for it and I don't think
it would be fair but I'm going to give
you one piece right now for free because
I know money's tight for a lot of people
and not everyone can afford to take a
class or or do a on demand digital
product but I also will make a special
offer for you uh at the end of this so
watch this video because I will give you
a way that you could try out the full
Suite of modern Story tools absolutely
risk-free which I've never done before
all everything I do is always all sales
are final you can't get your money back
I'm I'm going to make an exception for
the first two weeks after this video
drops okay but first let me give you the
free thing
so in my workshops and also for people
that since like six to nine months out
to take the workshops I have on demand
content I have a brand new thing called
the modern Story tools and it teaches
the five tools required to have success
in the current Marketplace compelling
conflict targeted
escalations Relentless Pursuit
intriguing question tool and deep Heart
of Darkness I want to talk about
compelling conflict um you might have
heard me say this before but as a former
studio and manager reader we're trained
if a script is submitted to read the
first scene or two and stop and if we
don't have to keep reading we don't and
if it's not WR compelling conflict
really good chance we're not going to
keep reading and I've trained a lot of
writers who like you know they do well
in the major uh competitions like Austin
and stuff but then once they learn
conflict and put it in there then they
start winning the competitions and they
get managers so compelling conflict is
so important and there's seven pieces
that you have to be doing I'm going to
give you one of the pieces right now and
even if you don't check out the videos
or study with me just this one piece if
you incorporate into your writing I'm
confident it will make a difference your
writing will improve so I will give you
one piece absolutely free and that way
if you're like oh this is cool I'd like
to learn more there's a risk-free way of
doing it okay so here's the one piece
that I'll give you and I'm going to do
it uh I'm going to tell you a story I
want you to imagine that we are in a
classroom at UCLA so you're in a
classroom with me and I'm teaching and I
get a phone call and I get this terrible
news that my brother's been in this
really bad accident and he's in the
emergency room at the UCLA hospital at
the base of campus and they have to
operate in 20 20 minutes or he'll die he
has a rare blood type they're out of
that blood type but he has a medical
emergency bracelet that says contact my
brother Corey he has my blood type so
Corey you got to get here in 20 minutes
or your brother's going to die okay
that's pretty meaningful stakes and
let's say in this scene my goal is I got
to leave the classroom like in the next
20 seconds so I can get to my car and I
can get to the hospital and I can give
blood so just to keep this simple in
this little short scene my goal is to
leave the classroom in the next 20
seconds and oh my God if I don't do it
my brother dies but what is in my way
what stands in my way a chair oh my God
there's a chair in my way now I think
you would say that doesn't seem like a
very good conflict design because that
seems kind of easy you could go around
the chair you could go over the chair
you don't know me I can't go over a
chair but I could go around the chair I
can move the chair I'm not limber enough
to go over a chair but anyway I can deal
with the chair and
leave so I had a goal I had meaningful
Stakes it was just too easy so let's
make it harder let's put two chairs
let's put three chairs does that make it
more interesting not really let's put a
human opposition let's say there's a
complaining student and they're like
Corey you can't leave the class still
has half an hour and I'm like my
brother's going to die and they're like
well people die all the time I want to
be a writer you can't and at some point
look I love you but hey I'm sorry and I
kick the chair out of my way and off I
go is that made it more interesting I
think so is it made it interesting
enough to make a studio reader want to
keep reading no it's not that it's a
little more interesting it's not that
interesting so let's make it even harder
and now let's assume let's have fun and
say this is a like a Quinton Tarantino
script so there's always a threat of
stylized violence and you're in the mood
for that and and so I explained the
class I got to leave my brother's going
to die oh my God the chair me way
complaining student okay just kick the
chair and then bam there's a gunshot
what and there's that that that that
student in the back that everyone knows
is wired a little and they've got a gun
and they shot it and they put the gun at
me and they're like I hate your brother
and you take one step towards that door
I'll will shoot you I will kill you and
they mean it and I know they mean it now
assuming this is tonally appropriate and
it makes sense you know this is like a
Tarantino type project and you care
about me and you care about my brother
this could get your attention th this is
now getting to be rather interesting
here's what I want you to take away from
this when I had to leave the classroom
in 20 seconds and what stood in my way
it was a chair two chairs three chairs
did you know could you confidently
figure out how this is going to resolve
yeah I was going to leave you didn't
know how I was going to deal with the
chairs but you don't really care
when there was a complaining student did
you know how it was going to resolve
yeah you were going to go out the door I
don't know what you were going to do
about the complaining student that was a
little more interesting than a chair but
you were going to
leave now Quinton Tarantino version gun
pointed at my head do you know how
that's going to resolve no you don't so
let's do the math so part of what I can
teach you in the modern Story tools is D
part of darkness which is required to
get people to really care about the
character so let's say you really care
about the character and the character is
trying to accomplish something and it
really matters to you how this plays out
and suddenly it looks so difficult you
don't know how it's going to play out
what does that make you have to keep
doing it makes you have to keep reading
or keep watching and that's why conflict
is so important the chairs were an in
Inc convenience I'm sorry let me let me
repeat that or let me let me rephrase
that the chairs were obstacles the
complaining student was an
inconvenience the person with a gun was
opposition opposition must rise to the
level that we have no idea how things
are going to play out so many writers
use a mixture of chairs complaining
student and person with a gun and that's
why they're amateurs doesn't mean you
have to have a gun I mean um you know in
the class or you you you can see
examples your own there's lots of strong
opposition that doesn't require gun is
anytime you're watching something and
you're like oh my God I have no idea how
fle bag's gonna get that priest to sleep
with her or I have no idea how this guy
is going to in the bear car is going to
get this guy to give him the meat at
Half Price like you just don't know but
it matters to you it makes you have to
keep watching that's why you can't have
a career if you can't write in Conflict
so that is one of the seven pieces and
if you don't check out the modern Story
tools if you don't take a class from me
if you just start applying this to your
scripts you're going to be a stronger
writer I'll tell you a true story so I
was in film school and a friend said hey
there's a screening you want to go and
I'm like yeah jumped in the shower ran
out got in her car and off we went I
didn't even know what the screening was
for that's the great thing about film
school it's like movie summer camp
someone's like there's a screening
you're like I'll go now I'm like what's
the screening where is it what is
parking like can I get some food you
know but back then I'm like screening
let's go so it was a Cohen brother movie
I didn't know that who was sitting two
rows behind me Joel and Ethan Cohen now
you know when you live in LA you learn
not to be Starstruck and I had done a
project at that time for Ridley Scott
I'd done a project for uh Harrison Ford
I remember getting lost in a parking
garage once and in Jack Lemon when he
was still alive I was there and lost and
we walked together and talked I got lost
in another I get I I get lost in parking
garages I always Park I go and I come
back this is for the phone iPhone I take
a picture I'd always like I know where
my car is and it I was wrong I've called
the police before I'm embarrassed to say
someone stolen my car no I just have
terrible sense of direction anyway I've
seen I met Steve Martin when I was lost
in a parking garage and I'm cool about
it I was geeking out that I'm a such a
little writer nerd little Fanboy that
was like okay after the movie Joel and
Ethan went up and they took questions
and they were talking about their
process and they said something that
just blew me away they said when we were
starting out we wanted to be writing
like the strongest conflict we knew you
know when you when nobody knows you you
got to write the best script to stand
out and get noticed so when we would put
our character into a real Jam if we had
a rule if we could figure a way out for
the character and
in less than a week we wouldn't use it
like when you're watching Breaking Bad
Walter White gets into a jam and he's
got 5 Seconds to figure it out and
you're playing along at home like I
would no I would die I would die no that
wouldn't work I yeah I would die and
then at the last second wal WR do
something and you're like oh my God
that's brilliant Walter White's brilant
Walter White's not brilliant there were
19 writers that took three weeks to
figure that out Walter White had 5
Seconds to figure it out so they said if
we could figure out a way out in six
days we didn't use it and I just
remember going what who whoa I didn't
realize writing could be that hard but
that is brilliant but then I was
suspicious like is that true or they
exaggerating I'm going to find out one
day and about two years later I was at a
party and Ethan Cohen was there and I
went up to him and I was talking like
you probably don't remember me but two
years ago I was at this screening blah
blah and you guys said the thing about
the opposition and I said he's like yeah
I don't know if he remembered or not but
he's like yeah and like I got to ask you
like is that really true like did you
really not use anything I just got to
know was that really true or did you
kind of exaggerate and he just kind of
looked at me and he said what do you
think he smiled and he walked away like
so I still don't know but um I shared
the story with my students and I've had
students saying I'm going to do that and
they have had a lot of success now I'm
not saying that you have to hold
yourself to this standard you can but
what I am saying is don't use chairs and
don't use complaining students go back
through anything you've written and be
honest with yourself or have someone
else read it and have them be honest
with you there's a really good chance
that at least one or two places in your
script or more the opposition doesn't
rise to the level if we don't know how
this is going to play out and if that's
true that's where people stop reading so
this could really make a difference now
here's the
offer so I have a workshop series and as
I said before you're probably sick of me
saying this I've had over 3,000 writers
who've taken it have success and yes I'm
saying that for promotional purposes but
I'm also saying it because I know what
it's like to be a young writer and think
this is impossible and here's the thing
if I could do it anyone can do it and if
these 3,000 people can do it anyone can
do it um but you have to be using these
tools of compelling conflict uh
Relentless Pursuit targeted escalations
intriguing question and deep Heart of
Darkness so uh in the past everything I
do is no refunds all sales are final for
two weeks after this video drops go to
my website and go to the free stuff Tab
and you'll see a link and what you can
do is you can try out the modern Story
tools and if you're not absolutely
100% excited about what it's going to do
for you we'll give you all your money
back and I know that there are people
that said I'll give you all your money
back but you need a team of lawyers cuz
they're going to make you jump through
so many many Hoops but um my principle
when I started out is just treat writers
the way I I would like to be treated so
it's going to be really simple if you
want your money back you're going to
email us we're going to go ah darn okay
here's your money back so that'll be for
two weeks after this video drops um so
you have nothing to lose check it out uh
these modern Story tools are a big
reason why so many of the writers we
train have success and I'd very much
love to add you to our list of
success